i'm starting today with something that
is the perfect nexus
of ignorance and nationalism i think is
the way i would put it
uh the unhinged nationalism in fact
of some of the new trumpian members of
congress really knows no bounds and it
even now is being applied to american
territories
whose residents are citizens of the
united states and i'm talking about none
other
than radical outrageous disgusting
depraved
and delusional congresswoman marjorie
taylor green
of course of jewish space laser fame
she said at a a side panel a sort of
breakout session at cpac
a couple of weeks ago that american
taxpayer money shouldn't go
to foreign countries like wait for it
guam now guam is of course an american
territory
the people of guam are american citizens
the reason it took us a couple of weeks
to hear about this even though cpac was
a couple of weeks ago is that it was at
one of these
breakout sessions so what we watched on
tv from cpac that wasn't all
they also had breakout sessions with
smaller groups where a lot of the things
said
were even nuttier and even more ignorant
if you can imagine that it was filmed
here is marjorie taylor green saying no
more money for foreign countries like uh
guam where everybody's an american
citizen and i wanted to take
my regular person normal everyday
american values
which is we love our country we believe
our hard-earned tax dollars should just
go for
america not for what
china russia the middle east guam
whatever wherever right
if we want to build roads if we want to
put money into schools if we want to
build border walls
we want it right here at home no more
money
for foreign countries like guam this
reminded me
of course and i think it reminded many
many others of the whole puerto ricans
should go back to their country puerto
ricans of course
are american there is no country to go
back to it's part of the united states
and
on a serious note this really does
reinforce
the importance of normalizing the status
of places like puerto rico and guam
and others green as an elected official
should know what is part of the united
states and what is not
but this is also another reminder as if
we needed one
that the way we deal with puerto rico
and guam and others like american samoa
it really makes no sense in many ways we
do treat them as if they are foreign
countries
there are different statuses for
different territories
people born on american samoa for
example are u.s nationals
but they're not u.s citizens people from
puerto rico and guam
are us citizens at birth it's a mess
and it needs to be fixed but what
foreign country does she think
guam is anyway now marjorie taylor green
is a [ __ ] that yes
she has no business being in the house
of representatives and
this proves that there needs to be
serious consideration given to the
status of overseas territories
she's in congress she should know
without a doubt
but the truth is if you ask your average
person in the street
is guam its own country or a u.s
territory
many people would have no idea this
isn't completely unique to the united
states i think if you go to the uk
and you ask people about some of the
more obscure british territories
i think many people in the uk also
wouldn't know but
the issue is people in government should
know
and these territories as far as the u.s
is concerned
do not have adequate representation in
their own government so
it's particularly it's a it's a
vicious cycle when they don't have
adequate representation
and then our elected officials sometimes
don't even know that they are lacking
the representation because they don't
even know that it's part of the united
states
unless it's convenient for some other
reason like for example
when republicans want to talk about how
bad a job
a democratic president is doing on
controlling north korea
they will say north korea could hit u.s
territories with missiles like guam
then it's convenient then all of a
sudden they figure out guam is a u.s
territory
there are many americans who don't
realize puerto rico's part of the u.s
puerto ricans are u.s citizens there are
some americans who think
new mexico is part of mexico rather than
a u.s state there's plenty of ignorance
to go around
but marjorie taylor green is an elected
official
and it's very politically relevant so
just another confirmation that she has
no business no business whatsoever
serving in government and hopefully
she will either not run for re-election
in 2022
or be voted out in a bloodbath election
let's hope for the latter i think it
would be more more entertaining
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical